(audience clapping)
- [Kelly] Have a seat. You look gorgeous!
- Thank you!
- [Kelly] Yes!
- So do you!
- Oh, well it's nice to see you.
We were just both like a
month ago at the Emmy's.
- I know, I was so happy to see you there.
- Oh, I, man.
- Like there's my girl up there.
- Did you have fun at it?
Cause I wasn't sitting at it.
- I had so much fun.
- I had to come in and out.
I was doing another job, so I came in
and out and I-
- Of course you were, I'm sorry.
- I was jealous that y'all got to eat.
I was like, "wait what?"
- Well, that was a first.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- The Emmy's this year
was really different.
Because in the past it's always just been
you sit in the audience
and you watch the show.
- [Kelly] Oh, I'd never been!
- And yeah, you sit in the
audience, you watch the show
and there's no food,
there's not even any water.
And by the end you're like,
"Ugh glamor is so hard".
(Kelly laughs)
- So this year they put
tables around the stage.
- Yeah.
- There were tables all over
the place, and there was wine
on the tables.
We were like, "yeah! It's a party now."
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But it was pretty funny
because our table, we were
like front and center,
but behind the stage.
So we had..
- Oh you were behind
the walkway?
- We were behind the like walkway stage.
And so everything that was happening
on the stage was pointed away from us.
So we had amazing views
of everybody's butts.
(audience laughs)
- You're welcome.
- I mean, I'll tell you anything
you wanna know about anybody's butts.
So I got to see you present.
- [Kelly] You're welcome.
- I got to see your cute,
cute, cute, cute butt.
And it was really one of
the best of the night.
(Kelly laughs)
- So I wanna say congratulations to you.
- I, I wanted to say like, it was so cool
I'd never been to the Emmy's.
So I walked out and I was like, "wait
they give like food and drink
at this one?" I was like,
"why is this
my my first time?"
- It was totally new.
That has never happened before.
- I didn't know.